bonjour et bienvenue sur diagonale tv
donc saint-quentin 2015 nationales
championnats de france 3e ronde 3e
auront d'ailleurs aujourd'hui on va voir
un petit tour du côté du national
féminin avec une championne
on reçoit pour la première fois soizig
net tv c'est andrea nawrot tescou je
rendrai à l'ordre à la vente et ce coup
pour présenter un peu au spectateur tué
dans une année faste de ce que tu es
championne de france junior oui cette
année avec une option mais ça fait un
bon score
oui ça va un peu comme jules moussard
alors ça donc ça fait 2 9 sur 9 chez les
garçons sylvain grande année alors pour
la france à leicester et je crois aussi
talus toronton bac cette année avec une
mention très bien et pas mal est bon
alors donc tu joues nationale voilà
c'est la deuxième fois je crois un 3e 3e
et bien tu fais est finalement un bon
début que ce que l'or aujourd'hui on va
le voir tu viens de gagner une partie
extraordinaire magnifique face à une
multiple championne de france parce que
c'est sophie millet kahn a gagné
plusieurs ça fait ça fait quoi de battre
une sur le tour de france
bah je me sens bizarre non mais je sais
que bon c'était juste une partie voilà
met donc en tant que résultat tu l'avais
déjà battue avant c'est la première fois
enfin si j'avais battu une fois
rapidement et on avait donné une
cassette donc c'est contre ça compte pas
le score était donc négatif est vrai
c'est la cinquième fois qu'un joueur
lent et j'ai toujours perdu
ah oui donc de là tu viens de portée
donc ça te fait quand même ça fait chaud
au coeur quoi ça fait répond résultat
compte et d'autre ce que content et on
va voir cette partie en plus elle est
extra extra ordinaire alors on va la
voir avec toi alors ça a démarré
tu avais les nez blanc tout à fait donc
alors c4 c4 donc c'est ton habitude
photos jeux des cas tous ces quatre ça
dépend de ce que l'adversaire joue donc
qui ont ces points des mets pas le pion
n'ont jamais tu là j'aime jouer
non non non ça te fait peur bah c'est
pas que ça me fait peur c'est que
changer de changer de répertoire comme
ça c'est un peu compliqué que ça fait
compliqué d'abord alors on y va
sous titre en perdant ensuite oui alors
et 5
c'est une anglaise de sang oui j'ai
train le fou qui valait la wii cavalli
ces six projets de ces cinq cavaliers
c'est 3 donc on sur ces pièces
normalement pas de problème la théorie
alors indécis ce délice de 3 à 6 à 6
donc elle prépare une petite case pour
son fils et sa fille rappeur de ce fou
se fasse prendre
oui donc à lui prépare une petite
retraite d'accord parce que quand on a
joué dessine on ne peut pas revenir donc
cavalier j'ai eu dès lors le cavalier
sort alors pourquoi eux deux et pars pas
en f3 tout simplement pas un extra tout
simplement parce que sa bouche la
diagonale du fou et ronald du fouillis
voilà même si si c'est plus souple
oui et puis c'est une naturelle x 7 x 7
notamment
oui bah c'est le set toujours la théorie
et la recul il faut jamais non pour eux
anticipé la poussée des quatre voies là
puisque des quatre attaques le coup mais
là ce matin l'un des quatre au moins ça
t'a plu voilà c'est ça donc ici je fais
et b3 mais trois donc ça veut dire tu
veux sortir se fout de ce côté là
puisque là parce que tu envisages pas de
jouer des quatre en fait si si mais plus
tard en fait d'accord tu prépares oui
donc est ici effet à 5
ah ça c'est un coup volontaire commence
après l'attaqué
impossible répondent mais en fait je
l'avais déjà fait une partie comme ça et
du coup je l' ai vu et j'ai pu me
préparer sur à chaque âge tu t'étais
papa est déjà d'accord
donc j'ai fait h 3 wii et h 4 bien sûr
donc acheté alors c'est classique on
affaiblit un peu le côté droit on a une
tour qui protège ici on veut pas laisser
les rages pranger 30 ça libérerait la
colonne tu vas tu vas me tue mouche en
fait exact donc voilà et donc maintenant
il fait est simple et la n51 coûts
extrêmement agressif parce que hp soit
5,54 c'est agressif f5 ça l'est encore
plus parce que maintenant avec le fou
elle menace au g4 donc ben moi je fais
dame c2 qui défend indirectement le plan
g4 c'est des fois directement conséquent
mettre d'accord comme ces deux tu
développes la dame si tu prépares en un
éventuel rock et sa visite n'a pas peur
d'eux qu'est ce qui se passe si j'en
prends bah je sais pas si dame via si
simple premier ou qui ont permis en tout
cas par exemple en 3 c'est ça et elle
peut pas prendre la route qu on sait ça
wyeth a pas pourquoi et la dame gcc chez
qui la vend chez les dames les six
échecs il faut parer les chèques et on
perd là le fou voilà c'est donc il faut
pas le faire d'accord donc on va revenir
en prêt dame ces deux il faut pas que
enfin ça sert à rien de prendre en tout
cas il n'y a pas de gain de pions et le
fait ici je crois que oui alors c'est
donc hop c'est l'avenue principale
claval 6
j'avais regardé deux coups et c'est pour
elle la place de cavaliers ashes envie
d'accepter qu'avait dit je sais tout je
pouvais sortir le web ce cavalier en
cette haine qui avait géré cette mise à
lula et hu estime celui l'enseignement
aux prises angers quatre prisons g4 et
ils s'enferment alger 6 non non pardon
d'alger sont d'abord plutôt envie
d'amuser 5,8 pour les noirs oui mais
augmenter la pression oui c'est ça les
noirs seraient contents aussi les blancs
étaient obligés de prendre les reprendre
vie c'est ça ouais donc je vais regarder
ces deux coups l'un est quand même à
jouer cavalier schiste du coup j'étais
hors de prépa donc oui donc déjà là tu
sais sortie de ta préparation donc ici
j'ai fait four b2 alors en fait je
laisse le pion g4 du coup oui mais je
comptais ont donné un échec angers 6
surpris pions projet 4 on peut regarder
pour être puis on prend g cup
tu aurais fait ouais échec chez lui n'a
pas peur de la dame se façon de fermer
ici mais je reprendrai un jacket
alors imaginons que l'euro à vienne dans
les fuites
oui puis un point g 4 puis on prend les
quatre faux prince oui ici il faut
prendre et menaces peut-être
5 oui donc ici peut-être j'aurais fait
feu à trois mais ces hypothétiques fin
j'avais envisagé cette vente mais je
n'étais pas sûr tu étais pas sûr et il y
avait aussi une possibilité
peut-être je sais pas pareil mais de
jouer d'abord cavaliers quand est ce que
la feuille de paye de jouer d'abord
cavaliers en en bakelite madame aïda ce
que tu ailles jouer d'un bed with the
way est maintenant de prendre des
remèdes à cary parce que les liens sur
france 5
et il ya aussi cavalier ces deux échecs
c'est une possibilité aussi donc là du
coup ça complique la vie rien mais oui
mais ça c'était c'est vrai que peut-être
un peu dangereux voilà bon ok c'est
comme ça j'aurais peut-être oui adroit
et 500 d'autres forcés il faut repartir
sans doute parce que sinon je vous ai 5
cette fois il ya eu 4 il ya deux pièces
en prise par donc on est obligé de
partir mais on affaiblit ce côté là peu
après sur un cavalier à 5 y avait trois
qui en plein accomplissement labour fait
jeter les possibilités de variantes on
va pas regarder tous ainsi il a donc ici
si elle avait pris 1 mais elle a pas
pris
grand qui me fait penser à wayne l'arc
est donc ici alors ok voilà alors ça
c'est surprenant parce que on se dit on
n'a pas envie de rock et du côté où les
lignes peuvent s'ouvrir parce que là il
ya le sens que ça va s'ouvrir
on se dit ami le roi du côté où ça va
chauffer quoi mais bon pourquoi pas je
pense qu'elle n'avait pas n'avait pas
spécialement peur de perdre a dit que je
pourrais la colonne par exemple avec les
pros f5
oui j'ai prononcé ça lui faisait pas
peur nouvelle reprendre du fou sans
menacer sa plaque la dame doit avoir
peut-être une calais avant parce qu'il
ya là d'ammoniac elle d'étranges êtres
embêtante donc ici et toi là il sait ici
que tu te décides à jouer le singe et 5
alors ce qui est symbole bien parce
qu'effectivement ça fait peur quand même
ce pion qui prend le fond qui vient
parce que là toi tu vas pas faire
plaisir aux petits sièges ont été
obligés de faire des inrocks donc tu te
dis si elle va prendre là sur cette
diagonale je vais avoir des soucis je
tue bush en fait en tant que ça je pense
à lui donne un pion oui c'est un
sacrifice de pions mais tu vas ouvrir la
colonne au ciel 30 bal c'est ça c'est
l'idée tu joues l'attaquent
oui j'étais d'humeur
combative et je redis d'eau qu'elle
prend oui ce qui forment naturellement
oui oui et là tranquillement interjet
alors à noter que le cavaly protège la
tour ce qui figurait la liane menace
quand même c'est fou échec et la tour
gan la dame donc qu'ici bas 20 18
elle revient blessé obligés et donc
n'est pas on le sait tout aussi ce parce
que les dessins vanasse est d'accord
donc ben grand roque
je pense que c'est naturel assez naturel
les tours sont liés dans le bus dans le
but d'une attaque on aime bien pouvoir
doubler les tours ou parfois sacrifier
une tour qui revient derrière donc qui
s'est fait cavalier sept cavaliers
recettes
voilà c'est ça qui est un goût mais je
pense que déjà la semaine - nice
trouvait pas super bien mais qu'elle
était vraiment longtemps réfléchi on se
demande si la wii parce qu'elle vous je
sais pourquoi je me rappelle c'est que
le fou ici évidemment attaque tout ça
donc si on veut jouer b5 et une contre
attaque normal il faut enlever d'abord
le cavalier parce que si les anglais
emprise il faudra mettre la tour en 2008
et après seulement on pourra vous
laisser passer ça donc afin de préparer
une contre attaque
d'accord donc moi sont alain belges ou
des 4 voilà donc le problème évident de
sortir le carrier ses comptes ou jouets
des quatre que
ya problème parce qu'on est un espion
prend la tour face à la dame et puis on
a on est bien content de pouvoir faire
ça parce que si le pion bouge le fou des
deux devient d'accord je vais donc là tu
devais dire il ya des souvenirs du
potentiel est là mais j'étais alors en
comptons donc ici la fin à quatre voies
la bouche
oui ici au moins on se fout n'attaque
plus mais toi tu a éliminé le pion aux
cinq qui bouche et la teneur de temps
fou mais maintenant à tout moment ce fou
peut désactiver
ouais c'est ce que tu fais tout de suite
maintenant je fais un calife 4 d'abord
tu fais d'abord cavaliers quant à lui se
passe ya une grosse différence entre
amis notre problème à avoir poussé le
pion en quatre c'est là qu'on se dit que
les mots ont raté quelque chose au début
parce que cavalière 4 il est superbe
slovénie - est-ce qu'on peut plus le
déloger c'est ça il ya plus de pions
pour enfin on ne peut pas il ya toujours
là ça fait trop on va pas vraiment hors
de question et là il ya plus de pions
fini donc il est si c'est un nom ce
qu'on appelle çà et là et donc ici
qu'elle a fait elle a fait baisser
j'essaye aurait pu faire tomber 8 aussi
mais pour cinq voilà il faut que le joug
du contre-jour
oui bien sûr sinon c'est impossible je
peins pas le pion parce que ce serait
oui un ralentissement de montech
l'habitude surtout augmenter la rapidité
de sa contre attaque l'ouvrir et la
colonna c'est pas le butin donc tu fous
des cinq malades et 5
alors l'idée de dessin qu il y en a 2 je
pense c'est bien il ya un petit contrôle
sur les caisses de 6,5 qui est quand
même une belle case cavaliers et puis
surtout ce fou de lui
déjà on commence à penser à des
sacrifices alors que moi je commençais à
me dire c'est rare des l'appartien plein
direct mais on peut prendre vous prend
ouais ouais tout reprend les chèques et
on sait jamais ouais enfin j'ai beaucoup
pensé pendant un parti qui pas sûr que
ça marche il n'y a pas de moment où ça
marche comme en mai mais on y pensait
déjà donc et ça fait peur déjà la peur
pour le noir alors qu'est ce qu'elle
trouve donc et prend un c4 elle prend
ses quatre ce qui est normal
oui donc ici se fait faucher
alors oui alors c'est la voilà cette
c'est là que c'est beau parce que tu
reprends pas un jeu tout joueur je
verrai normalement équilibrée reprend
vite vers l allemagne et s'est ralentie
en attaque encore là vraiment tu penses
à l'attaqué aurait de l'attak mois il
compte plus les pions tu peux plus tu te
dis je vise leur mère donc alors si
bizarre aussi parce que l'on se dit bon
il fait face à l'attack pourquoi pas
mais un coup comme tout a changé
qu'est ce que ce fut je ne fais rachat
boissard erc alors en fait le but des
secousses et de découvrir la la colonne
de la tour voilà la tour g1 voilà et
donc ici à tout moment mais dès qu'elle
vaille et prendre 1 4 sont possibles si
jamais fait rien de spécial on peut
prendre qu'à des curieux quant à tout
moment parce que le fou attaque g7
oui la tour aussi donc il ya tout
reprocher cet échec le roi en plus
obligés de venir ensuite et en bougeant
la tourner deuxième fois ci c'est encore
échec
donc on se dit il ya de l'idée ans pour
même envisager tout reprend échec louey
qui est le cavalier bout je parle en
bien et 4 et le fou fait chèque
je crois que c'est peut-être pas bonne
mais c'est possible de laisser passer ça
devient compliqué à calculer la défense
devient délicate donc qui sait elle a
pris en d3 alors elle reprend en b3
parce que si elle prit en c4 c'est
évidemment pour espérer ouvrir les
lycées des rentes cas de prise alors
sans doute jouer autour des 8 et b créer
du contrôle sur le roi blanc qui
lui-même peut se retrouver cinquièmes et
s'il prend b3 c'est toujours la même
idée c'est à dire mais maintenant les
blancs sont obligés de reprendre
on est d'accord c'est obligé il n'y
avait pas le choix et est donc vu que
les blancs au prennent après je peux
jouer autour des 8 g du jeu quoi en tout
va bien elle a du jeu mais je peux en
avoir aussi là ça commence à s'ouvrir
donc c'est cool mais andré gagnent pas
une joueuse comme les autres qu'est ce
que tu me fais six cavaliers pour m mais
la dame est attaqué c'est sa crosse
alors la dame est attaqué par le pion se
dit que je donnais une dame me 6 degrés
à elle donne des dames et on n'est pas
champion de france junior en comptant
les cacahuètes enfin que cavalier prend
le 4 complètement extraordinaire ce
qu'est ce que c'est que ce truc alors
donc là en fait effectivement on a peur
on se dit j'ai perdu une âme alors et
oublier la dame sur dix hommes puis on
s'attaque pas aux gay non non c'est pas
possible
elle n'a encaissé mais tout simplement à
tort j'ai tout rangé cette tournée cet
été donc on l'avait dit il y avait le
fou qui commence à attaquer la tour
aussi essaye c'est leur tour projet
cette entreprise ici donc le roi seront
obligés de venir
la suite est là torres auteur prend août
au rejet cesse autour du 6 ou si c'est
terrible two g6 et oui alors l'échec du
fou parce que tout le monde dont les
échecs des fous et puis la tour empêche
le roi de venir à noter qu'on peut pas
par et sur la diagonale d'abord de
donner le fourbe mais ça sert à rien et
si on est la tour c'est pareil s'il faut
prendre dans lequel un seul coup c'est
ouais h est inaccessible car les g5
échec et mat
et oui parce que la tour est protégée
par le cavalier ya échec et donc le fou
contrôle et la tour contrôlant les vite
le roi il mate un magnifique en ayant
donné la dame
donc le bilan des courses après calais
prend 4 qu'on ne peut pas prendre la
dame voilà mais en plus j'ai cette image
parce qu'elle fait
les secours enfin je sais pas oui sans
doute le seul ouais donc qu'à rédiger 4
voilà elle bouche
alors ça c'est un coup aussi de
championne et quand ils sont finis a de
la ressource et très jolis coups de
défense cavaler j4 puisqu'on bouche la
colonne et un cas de prises par les
blancs et bien damée perdu déjà parce
qu'il n'y a pas deux il n'y a pas de
match voilà que la dame est attaqué
vraiment donc là tu de vie humaine alors
elle va prendre le pied en béton est
donc toujours pas donc dans cette rame
ces trois là se moque des pions de rien
il faut quand même avoir des nerfs entre
fous dame menace matt donc sa meute
j'aime cavaillé entreprises mais d'abord
on l'autre aussi donc mais en plus une
menace m et c'est pas facile à paris
parce que l'on pouvait envisager tours
fc est par exemple ça protège le matin
je pensais que c'était pas tête
si on veut pas se compliquer la vie
qu'elles régissent injuste
jusqu'au bout j'y attache à tourner
sinon je sais pas je pensais qu'avec des
investissements j'espère
non ça marche vous ne sert non pas mon
métier ça marcherait encore je suivrai
le cavalier reste en prison la tour est
un malaise ça il ya une batterie la
biélorussie et comment ça fait beaucoup
et on se dit que là un effectif ces
choses donc pour dams et 3,3 recette
marche pas bien mais il ya une autre
ressource ont fait cavaliers ça qui est
l'interprète de carrie donc là le
cavalier bush l'année bonal il est
protégé par un pion on vous le dit
finalement une enfant sont sortis en
plus on se dit ils étaient à la bande ce
cavalier et puis la finale bizarrement
on se retrouve au centre mais c'est pas
fini
dans le cas ici du coup mon cavalier est
et quel jeu le maire angers 5 obligé
scène
alors là on se dit c'est pas mal parce
que bon ça bouchonne plateau lesparre a
maintenant deux collines couvertes oui à
tout moment ça peut s'ouvrir et puis or
là maintenant c'est ce qu'on avait dit
tout à l'heure c'est le pion contre la
casse de 6 13 ans donc on se dit toutes
ces pièces peuvent aller en russie ce
donc ça se finit le voyais rien puisque
si elle est arrivée en russie après une
prise et le kali qui reviennent
maintenant somalie des fourchettes et en
plus le cavalier là il n'est plus tout à
fait
stade stable parce qu'on peut jouer f4
il ya des problèmes donc je pense que
torres 6 pour ce public bientôt aussi
sévères sont finis se prépare tout
prendre en fait si ce pour éviter des
problèmes
donc du coup je mets mon cavalier géant
et 6 donc cavale et g on aurait pu
mettre peut-être l'autre aux six mois et
demi je préfère cela parce que ça me
laisse l'apurement g7 direct voilà on
menace étrangers c'est donc on force un
peu la réponse à la crise y eut le
prince prend du coup je reprends du
cavalier donc ici qu'avaient les prend
on va prendre toujours pareil on a de
nouveau la menace au g7 et la dame
l'attaqué donc on n'a pas trop le choix
faut donner la tour parce que si la dame
bougeait bien c'est pourquoi j'essaie la
deuxième tour qui arrive et ça finit par
faire cher donc tout reprendre voilà
donc je reprends est donc ici et fait
tourner vite évidence alors c'est
l'heure ça a mis du temps surtout que le
fou commencé à attaquer la tour et puis
on prend ça libère et elle met sa tour
sur sa parole comment ça va se dire
peut-être c'est le moment pour les noirs
perdu contre eux parce que peut-être et
prendra en b2 peut-être pourra
simplifier la tour contribution qui est
dangereux on l'a vu puisqu'il même jour
mais ça peut jouer donc ici je fais f4f
4 et systèmes les bouges voilà c'est
matt donc ici
elle a trouvé un coup intéressant que
j'ai vu que j'avais pas du dr des 5
alors très joli coup oui et on fait la
vraie menace ici alors non seulement il
ya un oeil sur 5 ha oui mais en plus sa
menace de venir en csn que c'est fait la
dame et perd donc voilà c'est donc ici
je pense que j'ai pas beaucoup de choix
donc lui fait robert crois bien qu'ils
aient cette vie qui enlève cette
possibilité de alors faut faire
attention parce que maintenant sur dame
fait sur par exemple sur tous ses saints
vous pourrez faire tousser 5 1 quand
même ici on vous donne des 4 par exemple
pour garder la batterie et il ya quand
même vis-à-vis avec le fou et donc il y
aura échec de la tour
4e on parle échec et ensuite fu panda
main et la finale est pas simple donc
c'est peut-être à éviter oui c'est sûr
donc après rob est un bon bain et
l'aurait prend à des intermédiaires
léché pauvres et là maintenant que tu es
content tu vas nous mettons un ouais
parce qu'il est protégé pour le club a
de fait c'est donc et le cavaliere est
attaqué donc là
elle est obligée de faire tour c'est
simple parce que sinon il peut pas
bouger le cavalier de sinon ce qu'elle
peut pas bouger parce que si ce calibre
bon jeu mais non c'est matt voilà ça
c'est de la batterie ou alors faut
donner la tour contre voilà mais ce qui
n'arrange pas particulièrement donc donc
elle préfère faire sur cet axe est saine
et on peut pas garder donc la dame
enlevée de le dire sur la même diagonale
temps ce qui permettrait de yannick
avaline puisqu'on peut y avoir d'autres
6 mais on perd la dame pour cech et lada
faut faire autre chose donc bon je fais
dames et 3 rebonds
oui d'accord donc il y avait une idée
derrière ce coup oui alors c'est quoi un
là-bas c'est justement on va le voir que
d'après parce que le feu a fait cavalier
que j'ai fait un cavalier 5 g 6 voilà
c'est l'heure maintenant on peut enlever
le cavalier a pu de maths et en plus on
le met là pour boucher un peu l'action
de cette tour parce que si il va
ailleurs il ya encore tranché cette fois
pas le choix cet effet c'est ça l'art
d'obtenir plus ou moins mais n'ont perdu
que la qualité ce qui est déjà beaucoup
mais il qu'ils aient pas encore
totalement
dans encore des gros soucis donc qui
sait je fais des titres des quatre alors
oui à tout est attaqué et le fou à 7
voilà donc tu marches de gagner une
deuxième qualité en fait parce qu'elle
va pas donner une pièce et bah il se
trouve qu'elle peut pas par et c est ma
mère est donc effet d'amérique
il veut activer sa dame parce que vu que
la dame est bloqué en des 8 n'a pas de
pour l'instant avait pas de case ici on
devait elle peut espérer venir en
doutant b5 et peut y avoir des idées et
qui est un pion à deux on sait jamais ce
qui peut se passer par là et là cubage
premier tome tu prends ton d'accord
c'est quand même pas trop avoir peur
parce que c'est le fou de cases noires
et le roi bon il surclasse moi même si
bon jeu prendra 2 oui mais bon je me
suis dit le permettra il met des biens
comme amy défendez la caisse des quatre
heures une autre idée d'ailleurs aussi
d'un mythe c'est qu'on enlève le fameux
un visage comme une tour d'un autre
pièce qu'en cas de prise du menacé aussi
de prendre ces scènes vous prendre
l'empreinte et le cas depuis on prend la
tour pour y rendre la dame donc elle
enlève aussi non seulement l'activia
dame mais allez-vous vis-à-vis quand
même qui était une vraie menace
on vous prend oui et maintenant
messieurs à reprendre du fou pas des
pions puisque sa bouche mais pousse et
ça c'est pas une bonne idée donc là le
fou est actif est bon les noirs se
disent il peut il peut encore rester des
ressources d'aider matériellement on se
dit quand même
un peu juste les blancs quand même
réussi là une magnifique attaque donc
ici je fais dams et rope en garde et le
vis-à-vis avec lecavalier
oui c'est à dire que le club ne peut
toujours pas bouger maintenant puisque
avec tours et d'anyama tanger cette
vallée mais si le fou est plus là il ya
toujours des menaces dans ma tente donc
ici main électif saddam yugo dames 1 4
comme à 4 la dame est activée maintenant
est ce qu'il ya des vraies menaces pour
l'instant non par instinct mais ça peut
venir alors en un cadre d'un petit loup
peut venir en bêta crac acquis anciens
de la dame et on peut activer le pion
c'est qui peut bon et puis au dernier
moment un cavalier pour y sauter et
faire des choses on sait jamais les
cavaliers en deux coups ici du coup et
qui a pas vraiment à ce jeu décide de
sortir m'en fous avec trois finales doit
tactile à dallas pièce qui aujourd'hui a
fini son travail un peu mais qui la tape
un peu dans le vide
tu joues en f3 voilà pourquoi ils
travaillent pas
en huit genres frotter à une autre idée
d'avoir un gène à trier c'est de faire x
5 effectivement attaque
le cavalier qui peut pas bouger voilà
tout à fait donc avec son lot d'amateurs
oui exactement
donc essayez fait ils font des quatre
attaques la dame donc là bas j'ai
plusieurs coups d'armes j'hésitais entre
d'un point cette dame c4 tout ça le mans
j'ai opté pour db2 le plus sûr de plus
sûres voilà elle pourrait continuer à
embêter avec fous ces trois oui oui mais
je sept mois et je sais je sais pas ce
que cette dame prend 1,2 comme prend 1,2
pour bouffer fois à troyes il faut être
et d'emprunter à wii / photo 3d prévu
parce que oui d'accord je vois trois
dames 3 2 il n'y a rien il est donc là
il a fait damas cinq à fait damas et
voilà avec une menace voilà simple mais
dangereuse fausse et trompeuse a déclaré
ban une dame et la dame 3 à 2 des
dangereux parce que si on prend 1,2
est-ce qu'on pourrait prendre deux
moyens pour rien points ça fait peu à
peu mais si je sais pas si c'est
vraiment dangereux mais bon la friche
est quand même aberrant bien ayant
encore en échec de la dame
ça fait un spécial spécial sur je
pouvais néant s'est dit ouais y'a pas
dense mais bon ok peut-être damme 6e
dames cécile pardon après oui madame de
synchro ces deux dom c'est simple
docteur de petites choses qui essayaient
de 13 ans voilà c'est ça d'accord donc
après dame prend à 12 non donc on peut
dans ma salle à il ya une menace et tu
joues au cou qui par la menace tout
simplement tour des trois cantons et
renvoie la up avec la tour je contrôle
la pub donc j'empêche mais ça devient un
peu tendue après le prochain coin c'est
ça oui parce que je vous sais ça voilà
se laisse pas démonter
il ya un court de ressources parce que
là le problème c'est que ça menace c4
ici là pour vous ben il n'y a pas de
case oui oui donc il faut s'en aller de
la colonne et si on s'en va il ya tous
ces trois kilos tout à fait donc on se
dit peut-être un des trois ans ce
n'était pas la meilleure car elle
pouvait venir en c1 à tour mais si elle
était venue en c1 peut-être avez-vous à
trois roues il ya des choses entre eux
donc
il a il faut pas se tromper calculations
elle est à ce moment là manquaient
vraiment de temps mais ça va j'avais
quinze minutes peut-être oui mais cette
fois c'est vite dit oui tu as joué quand
même assez vite parce que c'est toujours
on se pose toujours la question si
l'adversaire a peu de temps si je
réfléchis beaucoup ça lui permet de
réfléchir
donc il faut à la fois tenir compte du
fait qu'on a du temps mais pas trop haut
pour garder la pression autant sur
l'adversaire à ce moment là j'avoue que
j'avais vraiment beaucoup de pression
parce que je sentais que j'étais sur le
point de gagner
il s'était plaint encore ça et oui il
fallait pas se tromper ait un vrai tueur
vous regrettez pas permis de la nuit et
maïs et les siens donc tu vous fashion
qui soit 5
et là évidemment ça attaque les deux
cavaliers et on se dit que effectivement
eh bien on peut prendre angers 6
et puis derrière si les noirs prennent
un bain on prend avec une maille maths
et puis aussi en prolonge ici sont peu
menacé fuad cet échec suivies d'oedèmes
projet c'est donc c'est vrai c'est aussi
très dangereux et c'est même plus rapide
que la tâche noire mais a quand même
fait noir j'appelle joue non il n'a pas
joué on s'est pas tout de suite je vous
d'abord trois sets
voilà qui effectivement ralenti un peu
la taille des blancs puisqu'on a pris de
jeu de reprendre et le roi protège le
deuxième cavaliers justement je prends
gcs en fait et tu prends de 6 quand même
voilà qu'arrivent les prends parce que
l'idée c'est que en faisant ça soupire
devient dangereux aussi menacé d'aller
faire dame
c'est ce que tu fais tu sais ce que je
fais un précepte de cette très jolie et
pourquoi pas parce que dame
et si les noirs prennent en 7 et bien
d'un promat tout à fait donc toujours
dynamique jamais laisser souffler
d'adversaires
le pauvre il un joli coup de défense
oui enfin le seul je crois le seul c'est
un b 500 simple alors d'amener 5
d'où l'intérêt de pourquoi pas attaquer
la tour est ce qu'on pourrait menacer de
venir en c3 avec le fou cloud et la dame
et en plus on a un petit oeil tout de
suite on à nu sur huit
on empêche la dame donc c'est un conte
qui a l'air pas mal donc ici bas du coup
vu que l'auteur est un piège de la
bouger donc moi je prends un des six
tout simplement
voilà c'est ça qui est beau mais ça il
ya encore la tati continue la tour
prendre décide maintenant parce qu'il ya
plus de menaces
évidemment de clouage donc la tour
libéré et le problème est ainsi que les
deux tours attaque g6 avec un pion qu'à
une casse de dame perrine dame qui
attaquent g7
on se dit ah oui quand verra t on traîne
ça sent bon
donc s il est attachant ça évidemment et
c4 elle fait ces quatre îles pour
essayer de ces trois pourquoi pas
d'abord sa boucherie l attaque de la
dame insurgés 7
et puis on sait jamais ils auront quand
même manteau coincé près
pour y avoir encore des des possibilités
et et en plus la foule soit à tous cet
effet mais il ya la menace ici donc je
prends pas problème et menaces matt la
dame staff et donc on n'a pas le choix
c'est être c'est point qu'il faut
brancher alors à noter quand même elle
qui adam contre dame faut contrôler deux
tours matériellement c'est foutu mais
est ce qu'il ya un seul problème c'est
qu'on se dit plus loin et hyper
tranquille parce que en fait malgré le
fait qu'ils aient pas mal de pièces
autour de lui il n'y a pas d'échec il
manque un cavalier ou noir il a donc eh
ben je crois en g7 opt fric ils à leur
puce jouer
elle a joué gros hashemite un accord
mais elle aurait pu on va regarder
l'autre coup avant alors tu jouais aussi
rage si soyez bien sûr mais alors qu'est
ce qui se serait passé ici par exemple
pour g6 celle là ouais tout ranger 6 3 5
et maintenant sans doute comme j'ai deux
oies et voilà deux choses comme ça et là
on peut pas pareil à tour je vois la
dame âgée ya des morts partout il ya
d'amusant matin est tout à fait évident
d'ailleurs dam des amateurs ça suffit
non et un bébé peut pas venir donc
d'amener 3 suffit parce que en plus ça
empêche un échec de la dame cf
et là il ya convoque à rien en fait rien
donc
donc ça suffisait donc tout reprend g7 à
la du barça et elf héros hashemite et
encore il ya toujours magnifique dernier
coup
concluant est ce que là en fait qu'ils
encourent plein coup intéressant tu peux
même encore joué cette dame j'ai dit oui
parce que sa menace damas huit samana ce
tour g8 mais tu fais joli coup d'un
premier lettre pour conclure et on peut
pas prendre la dame puisque soi même on
fait un tacle à malte c'est beau elle
apprend tout le matos avec des menaces
amat derrière donc c'est une très belle
partie des comptes entre la rue parce
que pas de presque pas de faute à des
blancs si je compte à jouer presque les
meilleurs coups de mettant alors comment
ça se passe du coup pour la suite de ce
championnat à deux sur trois du coup si
beaucoup plus d'un congé pascal hier
c'était pas trop celle ci en a gagné
deux oui j'en ai gagné des wii donc la
première victoire et pointent de travail
au bureau
ouais et hier j'ai perdu compte ce
siècle où j'ai pas fait une bonne partie
malheureusement rien et puis bon
aujourd'hui ok pas passer ça c'est une
double champion de france montrent que
si tu avais jamais gagné ouais sauf une
fois en rapide oui mais ça comptait pas
alors comment tu vois la suite puisque
c'est bon troisième championnat qu'est
ce qui est difficile dans ce championnat
de france ce qui est difficile c'est que
c'est pas comme dans un appel ou quand
on perd une partie on se repose de notre
guide
le lendemain c'est que en fait on perd
une partie est malheureusement si on
n'arrive pas à passer à autre chose ça
reste est du coup on repère après on
repère voilà ce qui s'est passé -
championnat français nationale l'année
dernière donc très belle expérience
alors qu'il étudie ce coup en asie chez
ton général du montant des titres aux
jeux tirés à court terme ça serait
atteindre les 2300 actuellement 1 2275
et à long terme
ça serait titre d'amy pourquoi pas mais
bon ok après c'est j'ai encore du oui ah
oui parce qu'il est les points lyon sous
le régime qui s'est passé voilà c'était
donc un des gones al tv spéciale donc
avec andrea n'a voté ce coup qui a donc
multiples championnes de france sophie
liés dans une partie que vous venez de
voir qui est tout à fait magnifique une
très très belle partie d'attac
championne de france junior avec 9 sur 9
elle est pas facile de jouer face à
andrea merci beaucoup de rayons merci
merci nous avoir suivi sur des modèles
tv pour cette troisième manche du
championnat de france saint quentin 2015
et je vous donne donc rendez vous pour
une prochaine émission
au revoir